[Music]
[Applause]
Mr Jim nant is on the line for you well
hello friends look at you making some
time uh where are you right now
I'm back at the uh media center
having just come back from Butler cabin
and a little walk through of the Green
Jacket ceremony so
we're ready to roll man the weather we
know that's going to be iffy but what a
leaderboard we have here at the start
okay explain this that you had to do a
run through with the green jacket but
you've done this for decades
it's a it's as much a technical
rehearsal okay uh as it is anything else
when you roll in pieces you roll in the
piece that shows some of the moments in
the past at that moment of Coronation
and you have leaderboards to go through
top 12 and ties and of course you walk
it through with the chairman
and um you know there's a low amateur
that's going to be in all likelihood
stamping it's going to be a part of that
movie so we're just kind of walking
through the elements nothing too
stressful all right you called your uh
32nd and last final four in your
hometown of Houston how difficult was it
as the clock is ticking down because the
game wasn't in doubt of trying to kind
of pick the right words to finish up
it was tough I gotta tell you I I have
to say I I was shaking a little bit and
my voice was definitely trembling and I
felt like I was about to verbally
four-putt like somehow I was able to
close my eyes and go with the claw grip
and uh the words came out kind of the
way I wanted them to I had not
had anything written out or thought
through I know that raft at one point
maybe two minutes to go in the game
tried to engage in in that discussion
that just didn't feel right about it it
was a moment when UConn was celebrating
on the bench and and I made some
reference to this is their moment not
mine and I thought that probably would
be it but uh Mark Wolfe our amazing
producer uh
asked if I would uh no I actually asked
Grant and ref to say goodbye say goodbye
to Jimmy
and they made some nice remarks and and
then I came in was just some thoughts
some broad thoughts about what it's been
like you know to try to find the story
and to understand that we're covering
dreamers and if you just take a little
bit of time and listen to people
everyone has something to say everybody
wants to be heard
you know not just the social media
barking noise of people that want to
have a hot take on everything I'm
talking everybody everyone is listening
right now has their own personal story
everybody wants to be heard take a time
to listen and be kind that's what I said
and
he was at still 20 on the count to
commercial maybe maybe 15. and it just
struck me that it was a good time to
to say thank you for being my friend
was it always going to be Houston or was
there another scenario it actually
wasn't going to be actually in 2019
after Virginia won the championship I
started talking to
Sean McManus and David Burson and I I
told them that
you know my kids are young my I've got
my older daughter Caroline who was with
me in Houston and loves the final four
and the bonding event that has become
between the two of us but you know I
wanted it to be on a CBS year we
alternate years when it's it's beamed
out over CBS or Turner and nothing
against Turner it's been a magnificent
partnership that I thought my goodbye
should be on CBS so I said I'm thinking
maybe 21 in India it would Mark the
30-year anniversary of my first time
sitting next to Billy Baker and calling
it and lo and behold the the 20
tournament gets taken off the books you
know it was the week before covet really
became
um a cancellation event across the
country and we lost the 20 tournament to
Cove had to coveted casually so now I
didn't know all those months leading up
what 21 would look like I knew it would
be sparsely attended as we got closer
and it just didn't feel right and it was
during that time as I was holed up in
the Conrad hotel
with with three meals a day being
delivered to my door not allowed to
interact or even have a meal with raft
or Grant or Tracy
um this was you know this is not the
right time to to go out on I'd already
made that determination a couple months
in advance but it was at that point
where I looked ahead and said 23 is the
next time it's on CBS and it's in
Houston and it's just jumping off the
page and that needs to be the place for
me I'm into
contextualizing things and where
something starts something ends but
getting middle and an end and it felt
right to me it felt in symmetry
um that I started there and I would exit
the stage there started my career with
basketball through the University of
Houston basketball program it was my
gateway to the business and I wanted to
go back to Houston and make that the
place to step aside so it worked out
perfectly for for my purposes that I
can't just still can't believe how
generous everyone was um and all the
goodbyes I'm overwhelmed by it to be
honest and I'm trying to as much as I
can to get my head which is still in the
building back in Houston uh transported
Somehow Here to Augusta so I'm fully
ready to go this weekend on The Master's
Call but are you on the clock for how
long you're going to do the Masters
well you I think you might remember this
but yeah I've I've often said that I've
wanted to be able to broadcast 50
Masters
who put that in my head when I was
writing back to the compound in a golf
cart driven by Mr Venturi in 1986 we
just watched Jack Nicklaus win that epic
historic six green jacket and he makes
this amazing comment to me he says young
man how old are you and I said I'm 26 he
says I think someday you'll be the first
to ever say they broadcast 50 Masters
but you'll never live to see a day
better than that than this Around
Augusta and right there he didn't know
it he just set my goal he basically gave
me the game plan for my career and I
always thought as a tribute to Ken and
what's deeply in my heart this event I
wanted to be there for 50. Ken Venturi
said it to me when I was just three and
a half years out of college so I'm
making this speech Dan a few years later
well actually many years later in L.A
and Ken and Jack Whitaker introduced me
as bizarre as that sounds they're my
presenters and I told that story about
how I wanted to work 50. later that
night we're at the hotel Bel Air bar and
Whitaker looks at me and says Jimmy I
heard what you said up there about 50. I
said yes sir what did you think he says
you got to do 51. I said why he said you
do the math on it your 51st Masters will
be the hundredth playing of the Masters
and one of the sweetest things anyone's
ever said he said I think you need to be
there for that and I think Augusta would
like to have you there for that to be
able to cross one century into the start
of the second and so now Whitaker has
his fingerprints on that goal so I
adjusted so I want to be here until at
least 2036 God willing to have a chance
to do that do you have a green jacket
uh
[Music]
you mean like a windbreaker or no did I
mean shouldn't they it's like an
honorary
no no no no no
contributions to the game or something I
mean
hey I have been blessed beyond belief to
be able to come here this is my 38th by
the way on that tally and I still get
the chill bumps every time I step foot
on property for the first time every
year I return I just it's better than
than the last and uh no I don't have a
green jacket but I'm honored to try to
lend a voice to this tournament and
and
connect all the years you know golf
leans on History a lot
and this sport
uh yeah in particular but this place
especially is such a part of the
heritage of the tournament and that's
why you often hear me
well I'll go ahead and say it I was
going to save it for the weekend it's a
tradition unlike any other okay so I
um
I love history and I love how history
can be tied to any sport if you make the
effort and you do the research you take
the time I try to tie history in the
college basketball and now I'll never
call another basketball game and I have
so much history that's floating around
in my head that has no place to go now
there's no outlet for it so the next
time we're in the same area let's go out
to dinner and just let me talk for about
four hours a month of History so I can
open up some random space we're talking
to uh Jim Nance on the call for the
Masters coming up this weekend has your
wife ever said Jim would you use the
Master's Voice around me
no no no but I do get a lot of people
I'm serious who come up to me in most
random places
and it truly is daily
I would say there aren't many days in a
year that someone doesn't ask me to say
a traditional unlike any other most
people think it's a tradition like no
other that's incorrect okay it's unlike
unlike any other any other unlike um how
big of a storyline how big of a
storyline is live for at least in your
mind coming up this weekend live tour
players versus the PGA tour
I think that the master is just it
trumps everything it's it's the
Standalone event it's the greatest event
in golf yeah you know we've got Brooks
kepka uh In Contention here and uh he's
out early today and has an early birdie
so he's at the moment as we speak as a
One-Shot lead over Jason day who's
already started his second round and
Victor hoblin and John rahmer we're
going to go in the afternoon so kef is
the uh I'm trying to find out here I
think he's the only guy from that tour
that's in the top 20 right now and he's
coming off a win last week
um
it's not going to be ignored but this is
a Masters tournament this isn't about
all that other stuff that's going on in
the world of golf
yeah I agree and and I I hope that's
what it is you know but Brooks kepka is
playing Great Golf and you can't avoid
that that it's live tour cam Smith or
Patrick Reed whoever you know happens to
to be there and also Nicholson Scott
Walker he out there this morning already
making birdie or two yeah did you keep
anything from your last uh championship
game did you keep anything from Houston
well I first off I was presented all
kinds of wonderful gifts
um the governor of Texas governor Abbott
presented me uh with a proclamation
naming one of the weekend days uh after
May so uh I hope it was good to
everybody in the state that day that I
presided over it um
mayor Sylvester Turner in Houston uh
gave me a proclamation on the court
naming uh Saturday April 1st
as Jim Nance day in Houston and I kind
of thought maybe this was an April
Fool's joke they were going to take it
away from me but it held up I'm proud to
say
um you know I didn't
I take away a ton of memories first off
that's most important of all
but what I did is I brought things to it
instead of taking and what I brought
with me were
mementos
little pieces of of uh of my past that I
wanted to be represented on on that
night now I haven't talked about it
um maybe I just briefly on the court
made a passing comment about it really
has and nobody's
picked up on this not that they should
but you asked so my stats man and dear
friend Pat McGrath passed away on
literally the eve of the tournament
tournament started in Dayton the night
before he passed away in his hotel room
of a heart attack he'd been sitting to
my left for 30 years I was always by his
side
what I like to say and he was a
wonderful friend we did hundreds of
games together and everybody that's done
play-by-play work with Pat I wore one of
his ties as a pocket square
I had a tie on Forget Me Not time
um that um
is in honor of my father
and then I had on the table I had three
oversized pictures that represented my
career and I put my board on top of it
but I had really staring back at me when
I would move my board around a picture
with Billy Packer a picture with Bob
decas and Bob Fishman and Billy that was
my core group that did 20 of those final
fours together and then a picture of my
current group with Tracy and raft and
Grant and I had them all right there and
lastly leaning up against the monitor in
front of me I had a picture of my mom
and my dad on Saturday and uh just a
picture of my mom on Monday which marked
six months to the day since she passed
away and she was so excited about it
being able to attend one more event she
became immobile uh the last few years
was completely fine and all except she
was out of nowhere her heart gave out on
her on October 3rd and there had already
been talk about the goodbye in Houston
and that would be the last event she
could she could get to she could manage
to to get her into the building so I had
all of them in a weird kind of way to
looking at me and I'm looking at them
and it strengthened me because as the
weekend was going on I was more and more
fatigued and overwhelmed by it all the
tributes and the nice things people were
saying I just couldn't keep up with all
the correspondence I'm still trying to
get back to people but
um Monday uh morning I felt like I was
not prepared to do the game emotionally
I was teetering on the edge of of great
fatigue and
you know deep emotion not because I'm
saying goodbye it's just the fact that I
felt like I was the last link for a lot
of people that had worked that
tournament for nearly 40 years and I was
repping them
and I I just uh I hadn't felt that weak
uh mentally going into an event in in
decades
maybe since Freddy won the Masters in 92
and I didn't know if I could hold it
together then so
uh no
somehow became time to perform and um I
felt I felt good once the light the
tally light came on and I think all
those people I just mentioned uh
I was riding their shoulders to the
finish line
well have fun this weekend as always and
uh thanks for being a friend Jim
yeah you know I said that and I really
meant that
um everybody has a story and I just
thought everybody that's been a part of
that basketball part of my life for so
long I just wanted them to know
I sincerely mean it and thank you for
being my friend that's how I felt and
Dan
people don't know
they know you have a lot of guests
you've got tremendous contacts and
relationships you are a wonderful friend
thank you bud thank you Jim
that's Jim Nance will be on the call
coming up this weekend uh CBS also golf
channel ESPN